Guten Tag, mein Name ist Bulur. Ich bin der erste Kandidatin auf der Station und würde gerne das erste Gespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja.
Ok, so als würde ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen, dann direkt Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Max.
Max?
Max Müller.
Max Müller. Ok.
Wie heißt Ihr Name?
Max, M, A, X, Müller, M, Ü, L, E, R.
Ok. Wie heißt Ihr Name?
Ja, Frau Doktor, ich bin 61.
61, ok. Und wie viel wegen... Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
1. Juli 1964.
Und wissen Sie wie groß Sie sind und wie viel wegen Sie?
Ja, ich bin 1,71 Meter groß und wiege ich 91 Kilogramm.
91, ok.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausarztin?
Herr Wolfgang Stank, mein Hausarzt heißt Wolfgang Stank.
Mit K oder G?
K.
Wolfgang Stank.
Ja, Stank.
Ok. Herr Müller, was für Sie heute so ist? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Frau Doktor, ehrlich zu sagen, ich fühle mich sehr müde.
Seit drei Monaten ist mein Leben eingeschränkt.
Ich fühle mich immer müde. Ich fühle mich ganz schlaflich.
Ich möchte immer schlafen. Das ist sehr schlimm.
Denken Sie, es gibt eine bestimmte Auslösung für diese Müdigkeit? Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, ich habe 15 Kilogramm Wasser genommen in den letzten zwei Jahren.
15 Kilogramm?
Ja, ich habe Wasser genommen. Deswegen bewege ich mich nicht. Ich treibe keinen Sport.
Vielleicht fühle ich mich müde wegen der Übergewicht. Aber ich weiß nicht natürlich.
Ok. Haben Sie andere Begleitsymptome mit dieser Müdigkeit zum Beispiel?
Manchmal habe ich Kopfschmerzen.
Ich fühle Kopfschmerzen.
Haben Sie jetzt Kopfschmerzen?
Nicht schlimm, ich kann sagen. Vielleicht.
Haben Sie Hüsten oder Atemnot?
Nein, ich habe keine Hüsten. Aber wenn ich Treppe steige, fühle ich mich müde.
Ich kann nicht gut bewegen. Atemnot habe ich beim Treppe steigen.
Ich habe ein bisschen Atemnot. Aber jetzt habe ich keine Atemnot.
Während Treppe steigen.
Sind Sie in Ruhe auch müde? Fühlen Sie sich in Ruhe auch müde?
Ja, manchmal schlafe ich. Während ich im Fernsehen schaue, schlafe ich einfach.
Schlafen Sie gut in der Nacht?
Nein, nein, Frau Doktor. Ich schlafe nicht gut.
Ein oder zwei Mal wache ich auf und gehe zum Klo, um Wasser zu lassen.
Aber meine Frau hat mir gesagt, dass mein Schlaf manchmal in der Nacht zwei oder drei Mal stoppt.
Ich kann nicht atmen. Mein Atem stoppt zwei oder drei Mal in der Nacht.
Ich schlafe sehr laut, Frau Doktor. Ich schnarche.
Meine Frau hat immer Beschwerden über mich. Deswegen schlafen wir nicht zusammen seit drei Monaten.
Sie schlafen im Schlafzimmer, ich schlafe im Wohnzimmer.
Das finde ich nicht gut. Mein Leben ist eingeschränkt.
Ich brauche Hilfe, Frau Doktor. Aber das größte Problem ist, dass ich mich immer müde fühle.
Ich möchte immer schlafen, das ist sehr schlimm.
Ja, ich denke, Sie schlafen nicht gut. Deshalb fühlen Sie sich müde, Alltag.
Okay, wir werden Sie helfen. Bitte machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Ich brauche dringend Hilfe, Frau Doktor. Wenn Sie nicht helfen, soll ich meine Frau verloren.
Nein, nein. Bitte denken Sie nicht an das Schlimmste. Gibt es keinen Grund?
Sie beschweren immer über mich. Das ist sehr schlimm.
Das ist eine schwierige Situation. Aber wir werden Sie helfen.
Wir werden Ihnen helfen. Kein Problem.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen irgendetwas von chronischen Erkrankungen bekannt?
Ja, ich leide an einer vergrößerten Vorstellung.
Ich nehme eine Medikamente. Ich gehe in der Nacht ein oder zwei Mal zum Kilo und den ganzen Tag.
Ich kann nicht mein Haar genau lassen. Ein bisschen lasse ich mein Haar.
Aber nach drei oder vier Stunden gehe ich wieder. Das ist schlimm.
Dagegen nehme ich eine Medikamente. Ich erinnere mich nicht daran.
Ich habe auch chronische Lungenentzündung.
Chronische Lungenentzündung?
Ja, manchmal benutze ich Skriva Spray, wenn ich Atemnot habe.
Und auch leide ich an Bluthochdruck.
Was?
Bluthochdruck. Seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Seit 15 Jahren.
Und chronische Lungenentzündung. Seit wann haben Sie chronische Lungenentzündung?
Seit drei Jahren leide ich an chronische Lungenentzündung.
Deshalb hörte ich die Zigarette auf. Vor drei Jahren.
Ich gratuliere Sie.
Mein Hausarzt empfohlen aufzuhören, weil ich eine chronische Lungenentzündung hatte.
Ich konnte nicht gut atmen und musste die Zigarette aufhören.
Und Sie haben eine Schilddrüse vergrößert?
Nicht vor. Vorsteherdrüse. Prostat.
Ah, vorsteherdrüse. Entschuldigung.
Seit wann haben Sie das?
Seit ungefähr sieben Jahren.
Okay, aber ...
Ja, okay, verstehe.
Und Frau Doktor, ich nehme Amlodipin Tablet.
Amlodipin Tablet nehme ich täglich. Amlodipin.
Und ich nehme ...
Wie viel? Wie viel?
Zehn Milligramm. Morgen nehme ich. Und nehme auch Aspirin.
Mein Hausarzt empfohlen mir, Aspirin zu nehmen.
Er sagte mir, dass ich Risikofaktoren habe.
Welche Dosierung? 100?
Ich nehme 100 Milligramm regelmäßig.
Bitte holen, bitte. Ich habe nicht gut gehört.
Also Sie sagen, Sie haben Ihren Hausarzt?
Ja, empfohlen zu nehmen und ich nehme regelmäßig.
Okay.
Okay. Nehmen Sie andere Medikamente. Amlodipin, Aspirin und Spirovaspray.
Noch etwas?
Noch gibt es gegen Prostate, aber ich erinnere mich nicht.
Okay.
4 Milligramm etwas gegen Prostate.
4 Milligramm. Okay, kein Problem.
Haben Sie Ihre Medikamenteliste dabei?
Nein, Frau Doktor, ich habe sie nicht.
Okay.
Frau Müller?
Herr Müller, ich habe Prostate.
Okay. Herr Müller, haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzklopfen oder Herzstoffe?
Nein, ich habe sie nicht.
Okay. Ist Ihnen Ihr Bein geschwollen, Schwellung, Rotung oder Überwarmung aufgefallen?
Jetzt oder?
Jetzt, ja.
Oder seit 3 Monaten?
Vor 3 Jahren hatte ich einmal geschworene Beine.
Beide Beine waren geschworen und jetzt habe ich sie nicht.
Okay. Waren Sie für diese Beschwerden?
Ja.
Okay. Vor 3 Jahren. Sie hatten geschworene Beine und Atem?
Okay. Haben Sie eine Behandlung gehabt?
Ja, meine Haustür hat mir...
Oder haben Sie eine Diagnose?
Sie haben mir gesagt, dass es eine chronische Lungenentzündung ist.
Sie haben mir gesagt, dass ich sieben Tage im Krankenhaus behandelt habe.
Sie haben mir gesagt, dass es eine chronische Lungenentzündung war.
Ich hatte Atemnot, geschworene Beine und...
Okay. Und Sie haben im Krankenhaus geblieben für eine Behandlung?
Ja, sieben Tage.
Sieben Tage. Okay, ich verstehe. Würden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, mit 35 Jahren ist mein Wurmfortsatz entfernt.
Mein Blindendarm entfernt.
Blindendarm entfernt.
Ja.
Okay.
35 Jahre.
Noch etwas?
Haben Sie andere Operationen?
Nein, nur einmal.
Okay. Ich verstehe. Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin LKW-Fahrer, aber seit drei Monaten kann ich nicht arbeiten.
Mein Arbeitgeber hat mir gesagt, dass ich nicht arbeiten könnte wegen meiner Müdigkeit.
Jetzt sind Sie Arbeiter?
Ja, Arbeiter. Das ist sehr stressig.
Ja, ich verstehe. Das ist eine schwierige Situation.
Und sind Sie verheiratet? Okay. Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe zwei Söhne.
Okay. Sind Sie, sind Ihre Söhne gesund?
Ja, sie sind gesund.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Allergien? Oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Nein, ich habe keine Allergien.
Ja, es freut mich. Und sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft.
Okay. Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Ja, vor sechs Monaten war ich mit LKW ganz Europa gereist.
Okay, ganz Europa.
Nicht gereist, wegen meiner Arbeit.
Okay. Sie haben gesagt, Herr Mühler, vor drei Jahren haben Sie aufgehört.
Aber haben Sie rauhen aufgehört. Aber seit wann oder welcher Jahr haben Sie geraucht?
Wer her?
Ja, wie viele Jahre?
Ja, 35 Jahre habe ich eineinhalb Schachtel Zigaretten geraucht.
Okay. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, jeden Abend trinke ich ein oder zwei Bier.
Das ist nicht Alkohol. Wie Wasser. Das ist nicht Alkohol.
Okay. Und seit wann haben Sie trinken ein oder zwei Flaschen Bier?
Ja, als ich jung war. 20 Jahre, als ich angefangen habe.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie chronische Erkrankungen? Bei Vater oder bei Mutter?
Mein Vater ist leider an Superkrankheit. Er ist aber 88 Jahre alt.
Aber meine Mutter hat auch sehr viel geraucht und an Lungenkrebs verstorben.
Vor fünf Jahren.
Ja, es tut mir sehr leid. Okay. Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich bin ein Kind.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit? Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben ca. 15 kg in der Alp gegessen.
Ja, ich esse gerne. Besonders Fleisch.
Sie haben so genommen. Okay. Und haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Ja, jede Nacht. Wasser lassen zweimal.
Ich leide manchmal an Verstopfung.
Haben Sie jetzt Verstopfung?
Ja, das ist normal. Zweimal pro Woche gehe ich zum Klo.
Haben Sie Nachschwache?
Nein, aber ich schwitze sehr viel wegen der Kiloabnahme. Ich schwitze ganz stark. Das ist schrecklich.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen oder ein Eingefühl?
Jetzt habe ich nicht, aber manchmal schwitze ich wegen der Lungenentzündung. Während der Üstung habe ich Brustschmerzen.
Aber jetzt habe ich keine Üstung.
Ja, jetzt keine Üstung. Okay, verstehe.
Herr Müller, ich habe keine weiteren Fragen. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Frau Doktor, ich habe Angst natürlich. Meine Mutter ist an Lungenkrebs gestorben. Kann ich Krebs haben oder was habe ich?
Ich verstehe Ihre Sorge sehr gut, Herr Müller. Aber momentan gibt es keinen Grund für Sorge.
Es ist noch zu früh, um etwas Geniales zu sagen. Ihre Beschwerden können viele Ursachen haben.
Ich möchte sagen, dass Krebs nicht immer erblich ist. Bitte denken Sie sich nicht gleich an das Schlimmste.
Ich rate Ihnen, positiv zu denken.
Zuerst werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen, dann Blut abnehmen und einige Laborwerte und operative Untersuchungen durchführen.
Alle Ergänbisse vorliegen, kann ich Ihnen genauer sagen. Ich möchte Sie bitten, noch wenig Geduld zu haben. Ist das okay für Sie?
Herr Oberarzt, ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen. Haben Sie Kursleit für mich?
Der Patient Max Müller ist 61 Jahre alt, 1,71 Meter groß und 91 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Müller ist seit drei Monaten bei uns.
Er ist sehr schwer und der Patient hat manchmal eine Schmerz- und Belastungsabhängigkeit.
Er hat eine Schmerzabhängigkeit.
Er hat erwähnt, dass er im Schlaf Lautschnarchen und Atemstillstand hat.
Ich habe eine Schmerzabhängigkeit.
In der vegetativen Anamnese ergaben sich ca. 15 Kilogramm Gewicht von zwei Jahren.
Der Patient hat eine Schmerzabhängigkeit.
Ich habe eine Schmerzabhängigkeit.
In der vegetativen Anamnese ergaben sich ca. 15 Kilogramm Gewicht von zwei Jahren.
Der Patient hat eine Schmerzabhängigkeit.
Er hat eine Schmerzabhängigkeit.
Er leidet seit 15 Jahren an Arteriellehypertonie.
Seit 7 Jahren leidet er an Prostata-Hyperplasie.
Seit 3 Jahren leidet er an chronische Lungenerkrankungen.
Er leidet seit 10 Mg morgens an Amrydipin.
Er leidet seit 100 Mg morgens an Acetylsalazylsäure.
Er leidet seit 1-1,5 Mg morgens an Spray.
Er nimmt eine Medikament gegen meine Prostata-Hyperplasie.
Aber der Name und die Dosierung der Medikament sollten geklärt werden.
Er ist nicht Raucher, aber zuvor er Rauchte.
Er habe seit 35 Jahren 20 Zigaretten pro Tag geraucht.
Er trinkt ein oder zwei Flaschen Bier seit ca. 40 Jahren.
Er trinkt keine regelmäßigen Sportarten.
Er ist in der Familie Nanamnese angegeben.
Sein Vater hat Diabetes-Militis Typ 2.
Seine Mutter ist verstorben.
Er ist jetzt arbeitslos, aber zuvor arbeitete er als Lkw-Fahrer.
Er ist verheiratet, hat zwei gesunde Sonne.
Er ist vollständig geimpft und hat keine bekannten Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten.
Die Anamnistischen Angaben deuten am ehesten auf eine Schlafapne hin.
Als Differentialdiagnosen kommen in Betracht Hypotheroise und Schmerzen.
Die Symptome sind sehr wichtig.
Die Anamnistischen Angaben deuten am ehesten auf eine Schlafapne.
Er hat Schnorcken, Metabolischen Syndrome.
Er hat Schnorcken übergewickelt und hat einen Atemstillstand vorgeschrieben.
Diese Symptome sprechen für eine Ossas oder Schlafapne.
Die Anamnistischen Angaben deuten am ehesten auf eine Schlafapne.
Ich werde den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Ich stelle anatomische Pathologien fest.
Zum Beispiel Tonsilpapillase oder Nasendeviation.
Ich auskultiere Lungen, um die anderen Lungen pathologien auszuschließen.
Welche anderen Lungen auskultieren Sie?
Ich kenne zwei Lungen. Gibt es noch weitere Lungen?
Nein, nicht Lungen. Lungenkrankheit oder Lungenerkrankung.
Pulmenärerkrankung.
Ich auskultiere die Lungen und das Herz.
Ja, ich auskultiere die Lungen und das Herz.
Das Herz.
Ja, die Lungen und das Herz.
Und ich kontrolliere die beiden Beine um die Oedämme und um die peripherale Oedämme auszuschließen.
Dann würde ich Blut abnehmen und einige Laboparameter überprüfen.
Zum Beispiel ein großes Blutbild, Entzündungparameter, BCG, BSG, und CRP.
Und um die Nieren-, Lebewerte- und Elektrolytin- und meine Differenzdiagnosen auszuschließen,
würde ich die Troidehormone bestimmen lassen.
Welche Troidehormone bestimmen lassen?
TSH und FTE4 und 3.
Und um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich die Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Und eine Schlaflabo-, eine Polysomnographie durchführen.
Und eine Rundgangsdorax-Zweie benen, um die möglichen Lungenerkrankungen und Lungenpathologien auszuschließen.
Sollte sich meine Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, schlage ich die folgende Therapie vor.
Ich empfehle den Patienten eine Ernahrungsumstellung und Gewichtsreduktion.
Und eine Alkoholkaranz auf und Bewegung um die Gewichtsreduktion.
Und ich empfehle den Patienten eine Beatmungstherapie mit einem Gerät.
Und die Sipaptherapie.
Ich empfehle den Patienten die Sipaptherapie.
Und der Patient, falls der Patient eine anatomische Pathologie hat, eine Schürrige Therapie empfehlen.
Alles ist das.
Herr Kollege, wie können Sie Hypotheroide ausschließen?
Hypotheroide.
In dieser Untersuchung können wir mit dem Hormon Hypotheroide ausschließen.
Und?
Die Körperversuchung kann einige Dinge, zum Beispiel Haare aus Fall oder Verstöpfung oder Mülligkeit.
Schilddrüse?
Ja, natürlich Schilddrüse.
Synographie?
Synographie auch können wir machen.
Aber in diesem Fall, diese Untersuchung, ich glaube gegebenenfalls können wir durchführen.
Wie können Sie Lungenkrebs ausschließen?
Ja, für Lungenkrebs, ich denke eine CT-Torax durchführen.
Und wenn wir eine Tumore, falls wir einen Tumor bestätigen, müssen wir eine Biopsie entnehmen.
Wie können Sie eine Biopsie entnehmen?
Mit Bronchoscopy können wir eine Gewebeprobe entnehmen.
Können Sie uns Bronchoscopy aufklären?
Bronchoscopy ist eine Untersuchung, um mögliche Lungenerkrankungen bestätigen.
Wir benutzen eine flexible Schlacht bis zum Lungen.
Und am Ende dieses Schlusses gibt es eine Kamera.
Schluss oder Schlauch?
Schlauch, ja, Schluss und Schlauch.
Flexible Schlauch.
Und mit dieser Kamera können wir die Struktur der Wand und möglichen Tumoren sehen.
Und wir können eine Gewebeprobe entnehmen.
Das ist eine Invasive.
Für diese Untersuchung muss der Patient keine Vorbereitung machen.
Nein, ich bin wieder aufgeregt.
Es soll vor der Untersuchung sechs Stunden nüchtern sein.
Wir geben den Patienten leichte Schlafmittel.
Wir machen auch örtliche Betäubung.
Nach der Untersuchung sollte der Patient keine wichtigsten Dinge machen.
Zum Beispiel Autofahren oder eine Dokumente unterschreiben.
Der Patient sollte sie in Jemen bringen.
Warum?
Weil es gebraucht wird.
Nach der Untersuchung sollte der Patient nicht allein bleiben.
Deshalb braucht der Patient Jemen.
Der Patient soll eine Begleitperson mitbringen.
Die Person, die nach Hause zurückkommt.
Ja.
Ist diese Untersuchung schmerzlos?
Eigentlich ist diese Untersuchung schmerzlos.
Aber während der Schlauchanführung kann der Patient etwas Schmerz fühlen.
Wir geben den Patienten leichte Schlafmittel.
Deshalb geben wir Schmerzmittel oder eine örtliche Betäubung.
Gibt es eine Komplikation in dieser Untersuchung?
Ja, einige Komplikationen können durchgeführt werden.
Zum Beispiel eine Infektion oder eine Perforation.
Eine Perforation, ja.
Blutung?
Blutung natürlich.
Allergie?
Ja, Allergie.
Aber wir haben eine Kontrastmitte.
Aber wir haben eine Kontrastmitte?
Nein.
Beruhigungsmitte.
Gegen.
Gegen Beruhigungsmitte, okay.
Bende, das geht nicht.
Okay, vielen Dank, Herr Kollegen.
Vielen Dank, Herr Oberarzt.
Wir haben heute einen neuen Patienten.
Ich möchte mit Ihnen den Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja bitte.
Es handelt sich um Max Müller.
Max Müller ist 61 Jahre alt.
1 Meter 71 groß und 91 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Müller stellte sich bei uns heute wegen seit 3 Monaten bestehender Fatigue und Schlafligkeit vor.
Die Frau des Patienten hat bemerkt, dass der Patient Atemstillstand und Schnurren beim Schlafen hat.
Der Patient berichtete über einen Gewisssunami von 15 Kilogramm innerhalb von 2 Jahren.
Außerdem leidet er unter Sefalgie.
Der Patient, die Vegetative Anamnese, ist folgende bekannt.
Obstation, Nitri, Hyperhydrosis und Insomni.
An der Erkrankung sind seit 50 Jahren Arteriehypertonin, seit 2 Jahren chronische Obstruktur pulmoner Erkrankungen,
seit 2 Jahren eine Prostathyperplase.
Im Besuch der Medikation nimmt er einen Spray bei Wetter gegen chronische Obstruktur pulmoner Krankheit.
Amblodipin Tablet 10 Milligramm einmal täglich, Aspirin 15 Milligramm einmal täglich.
Außerdem nimmt er eine Tablette gegen Prostathyperplase ein.
Die Dosis und die Name sollten geklärt werden.
Der Patient wurde mit 35 Jahren an einer Ependektomie durchgeführt.
Die Frage nach Allergie wurde verneint.
Er ist seit 2 Jahren nicht Rauchherin, aber er hat 25 Jahre eine Schachtel Zigarette geraubt.
Er trinkt Bier und Wein.
Im Besuch der Familienanamnese teilt er mit, dass die Mutter an Bronchialcarcinoma vor 5 Jahren gestorben ist.
Der Vater hat Diabetes mellitus.
Er tritt keinen Sport.
Er arbeitet als Führer, RKW Fahrer.
Aber jetzt ist er arbeitlos.
Er ist verheiratet und hat 3 Söhne.
Die Söhne sind gesund.
Ich habe einen Verdacht auf Schlafapne-Syndrome.
Da der Patient Symptome dafür aufweist,
leidet der Patient unter Atemstillstand und Schnurrschun beim Schlafen.
Außerdem klagt er über Fatigue.
Das ist Schleifapne-Syndrome.
Ich habe einen Verdacht auf Asdifferentialdiagnose.
Es gibt auch Hypothyroid und Bronchialcarcinoma.
Um meine Verdacht Diagnose zu bestätigen,
würde ich zunächst den Patienten die Widerstandsparameter überwachen.
Dann würde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf,
dass ich Schwere am Bein, Farbeänderung und Lippen am Lippen habe.
Und eine Vergrößerung am Thyroid vorliege.
Außerdem auskultiere ich Lungen und die Lungen und das Herz.
Außerdem teste ich das Thyroid ab, ob es eine Knoten- und Vergrößerung gibt.
Neben der körperlichen Untersuchung wäre ein Laborunterzugs-Symbol,
um die Diagnose zu bestätigen.
Dabei wurde ich ein kleines Blutbild.
CRP, BSG, TSH, T3, T4 und Lebewerte.
Ich würde die Widerstandsparameter bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich ein Symbol der Lungen aufnehmen.
Und eine Thyroid-Syntagraphie und ein GGB-Nahmfass-Theroids-Synagraphie durchführen.
Und eine Thyroid-Syntagraphie.
Außerdem würde ich eine Stidessades durchführen, um mögliche Gehirn-Pathologien auszuschließen.
Sollte sich mein Verdachtdiagnos bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Dann würde ich die Physik herabreißen.
Dann würde ich die Therapie aufnehmen.
Dann würde ich die Nase positiv ausüben.
Dann würde ich den Patienten die Lebensstile verändern.
Dann würde ich den Patienten die Schlafposition ändern.
Dann würde ich schlafen in einer Seitenlage.
Dann würde ich die Gewichtsreduktion, Alkoholkehren und Sedative machen.
Und es wäre ein Symbol, wenn ich eine HNO-Konsultation anordne, um meine Therapie des Patienten zu optimieren.
Wenn Sie in dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit dieser geplanten Untersuchung fortsetzen.
Herr Kollegen, wie können Sie eine Anämie ausschließen?
Ich werde die Anämie ausschließen und werde erst ein kleines Blut veranlassen.
Was können Sie bei der Körperlosenversuchung für eine Anämie ausschließen?
Sie haben recht, Herr Oberst.
Ich werde darauf achten, ob es eine Lippen- oder Konjunktiv-Plätze gibt.
Oder ob der Patient eine Tachikardie hat oder ob es eine Nagel-Plätze gibt.
Herr Kollege, wie kann man einen Gewichtsverlust machen?
Ich empfehle den Patienten, Diätisten zu machen.
Ja, genau. Ich empfehle, dass die Diätprogramme z.B. niedrige Kalorien essen.
Wie können Sie Hypothyroise ausschließen?
Ich würde die Thyroid-Parameter TSH, T3 oder T4 veranlassen.
Außerdem würde ich den Patienten die Thyroid-Synthesisierung ausführen.
Würden Sie die Thyroid-Synthesisierung ausführen?
Herr Kollege, wie können Sie die Metabolischen Syndroma ausschließen?
Die Metabolischen Syndroma, ja.
Ich habe keine Erfahrung über das Thema, Herr Oberst.
Nach der Prüfung werde ich das Thema nachschlagen.
Vielen Dank, Herr Kollege. Meine Frage ist fertig.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen, den ich eben in der Notaufnahme gesehen habe.
Ja bitte.
Es geht um Max Müller, ein 61-jähriger Patient, geboren am 01.07.1964.
Er ist 1,71 Meter groß und 91 kg schwer.
Er stellt sich bei uns vor aufgrund seit drei Monaten bestehender, zunehmender Fatigue sowie Somnolanz.
Als Begleitsymptomen liegt Cephalgie, ein Bewegungsabhängiger, vor.
Der Patient klagt über Apnoe und Schnarchen.
Seine Frau beschreibt Apnoe und Schnarchen.
Die Frage nach der Tachikalie und der Odemaschüste wurde verneint.
In der vegetativen Anamnese fanden sich Gewichtsunamenspannungen, 15 kg in einem Jahr,
und eine Obstipation mit Dürich zweimal pro Nacht.
Er hatte an Vorerkrankungen seit 7 Jahren Kronosobstruktive Lungenerkrankungen.
Er nimmt gegen die Arterielle Hypertonik seit 15 Jahren, dagegen 10 mg Amlodipin morgens ein.
Darüber hinaus nimmt er 100 mg Aspirin ein.
Bei ihm wurde ein Appendiktum vor 35 Jahren durchgeführt.
Er wurde wegen Lungenerkrankungen stationär behandelt.
Bei ihm sind Allergien und Unverträglichkeiten nicht bekannt.
Er ist seit 3 Jahren nicht Raucher.
Davor habe er 35 Jahre lang 1,5 Schachteln Zigaretten geraucht.
Er trinkt 1-2 Flaschen Bier seit 41 Jahren.
Drogenkonstruktion wurde verneint.
Er ist verheiratet. Er lebt mit seiner Frau zusammen.
Er hat zwei gesunde Söhne.
In der Familienanamnese fand sich Diabetes Melitus bei dem Vater.
Bronchialkarsinom bei der Mutter.
Die Mutter ist vor 5 Jahren an Bronchialkarsinom verstorben.
Er ist vollständig geimpft. Reiseanamnese ist unauffällig.
Meine Verdacht Diagnose lautet auf Schlafabneuesyndrom.
Dafür schiebt Abneuer, Schnarchen, Fatigue, Schlafrigkeit.
Differenzielle Diagnostik kommen.
Hypotheriose, Herzinsuffizienz, Lungenembolie in Betracht.
Für Diagnostik würde ich zunächst eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Dabei würde ich den Patienten inspezieren, palpieren und auskultieren.
Bei der Inspektion beurteile ich allgemeinen Zustand des Patienten.
Bei der Vergrößerung des Halses achte ich darauf, eine mögliche Schichtdrüsevergrößerung zu machen.
Bei der Auskultation auskultiere ich Lungen, um eine Lungenödem auszuschließen.
Zur weiteren Diagnostik würde ich eine Laboruntersuchung durchschauen, um Blutbild- und Thyroidwertschichtdrüsenwerte,
darunter T3, T4, TSH und D-Dimer pro BNP-Werte zu bestimmen.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich eine Polysomnographie durchführen.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich die folgende Therapie empfehlen.
Gewichtsreduktion, Lebensstiländerung und gegebenenfalls einen chirurgischen Eingriff.
Eine Therapie empfehlen oder anordnen?
Herr Kollegen, Sie haben gesagt, als differential Diagnose kommen Herzinfizienz in Frankreich. Wie können Sie Herzinfizienz ausschließen?
Zunächst würde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchschauen, ob es eine Ödeme im Lungen und im Bein gibt.
Danach würde ich den Patienten auskulturen, um eine mögliche Lungenödem zu beurteilen.
Aber das Goldstandard ist die Echokardiographie. Bei der Echokardiographie messen wir Ejection-Fraktion.
Würden Sie in diesem Fall eine EKG schreiben?
Oder Herzrhythmus-Störungen ausschließen.
Wie können Sie eine Lungenembolie ausschließen?
Um eine Lungenembolie ausschließen, würde ich Laborunterzüge durchschauen, dabei würde ich Dedima verteilen.
Was würden Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung um eine Lungenembolie ausschließen?
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung müssen wir die Vitalparameter bei einer Lungenembolie mit Sauerstoffseitigung vermindern.
Das Goldstandard ist die CT-Thorax mit Kontrastmittel.
Ja, ich habe gehört. Aber jetzt erinnere ich mich nicht daran.
Können Sie uns die Ventilationsperfektionssyntagraphie erklären?
Nein. Würden Sie in diesem Fall eine Dublaksonographie durchführen? Und warum?
Ich würde eine Dublaksonographie durchführen. Die Dublaksonographie ist bei der tiefen Trombose entscheidend. Ich denke, in diesem Fall nicht tiefen Trombose.
Um eine Lungenembolie und TFT ausschließen, würde ich eine Dublaksonographie durchführen.
Können Sie uns Polysomnographie aufklären?
Wenn Sie die TFT-Syndrom diagnostizieren, übernachten Sie die Patienten zu Hause.
Zu Hause oder im Labor?
Zu Hause. Entschuldigung, im Krankenhaus, im Schlafmau.
Ja, übernachten und wir auszeichnen bei der Untersuchung Sauerstoffsetigung und Atemstillstand.
Ja, richtig Herr Oberhass. Wir auszeichnen viele Parameter.
Diese Untersuchung ist schmerzfrei. Man sollte nicht vorbereiten. Nach der Untersuchung gibt es keine Aufwilligkeit.
Ich würde Ihnen den Antrag auf Ihrem Alltag wie gewohnt fortsetzen.
Okay, meine Frage ist fertig. Jetzt.